I'm meeting here with our members in bury
and our parliamentary candidates,
who are a fine body of men who are experienced and enthusiastic.
And we're running for election in bury.
But here's the news. I'm coming to bury to support them.
We're going to have a rally in bury
in support of the Workers Party candidates.
So if you support me, if you support Gaza,
if you support Palestine, and if you hate the fact that Labour
and the conservatives are up to their neck in Palestinian blood,
you come and see me in bury over the next few days.
Stay tuned for the details.
And we are proud that we have chosen them.
Workers Party and our charismatic leader,
Mr George Galloway.
And we are very proud to work under the shadow of Mr George Galloway.
Thank you, bro.
We gonna smash when he's gonna come to bury.
I think it's gonna be smashed.
Would be easy. Easy for us.
Yeah, it's gonna be.
It's gonna be a victory for us.
We need your support and bury people,
everybody's support worker party.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Please join Worker Party as well, everybody.
We have already already said to the Burry people
that they gonna join the Workers Party.
So after this, when Mister George Galloway arrives in Burry,
so we have
lots of people are coming and they're gonna join the workers bar.
Labor are finished in Barrett.
They're finished in Greater Manchester.
Yes, they're Finished in the Midlands,
in Birmingham. They're finished in East London.
Yes. Because people don't want to be associated with genocide.
Absolutely.